[Music]
Have you ever wondered where farmers get
the seeds they plant to produce the
foods that we eat? Sometimes farmers
continue planting seeds saved from the
previous crop. However, for some of our
most common crops, including corn,
onion, spinach, and broccoli, farmers
purchase seeds each year. To understand
why, let's explore plant genetics using
corn as an example. Different genes
dictate the sweetness of the kernel,
plant height, ear size, and other
traits.
[Music]
Different varieties of corn have the
same genes. However, they have different
versions of those genes which lead to
unique characteristics like color and
resistance to pests.
Consider the produce in your grocery
store. Farmers produce uniform crops so
that they can be easily cared for,
harvested, and sold to consumers. If all
the corn in the field grew at different
rates, the plants would vary in their
needs for water and nutrients. For this
reason, an extraordinary amount of
breeding is used to produce uniform
varieties that are useful to farmers.
These inbredad crops take years to
produce and are often bred and
maintained by seed companies or
university researchers. To understand
inbredads, let's use an analogy.
You can think of genes as playing cards
and other suits of the same card as
different versions of the same gene.
In many plants, as in humans, each
individual has two versions of every
gene. In imbreds, all genes can be
represented by the same suit. For
example, one plant might have all hearts
and another all spades.
Then, if you cross two different inbred
plants, the result is a hybrid that is
exactly half hearts and half spades.
Nearly a hundred years ago, breeders
observed that making a hybrid of two
inbred varieties results in a new
variety that has better characteristics
than either parent. These hybrids make
great crops for two reasons. They are
genetically identical to each other like
twins and are therefore uniform. And
unlike their parents, they have two
different versions of every gene, giving
them hybrid vigor. This results in
favorable characteristics such as
resistance to pests
and higher yields. Now farmers can grow
their hybrid crop, harvest, collect
seeds, and plant them next season.
Right? Let's look at what would happen.
Each hybrid has one heart version and
one spade version of each gene. To
produce the next generation, each
hybrid's parent randomly passes down one
version of each gene. The next
generation will not be uniform. Some
plants will have two heart varieties of
a given gene. Some will have two spades
and some will have one of each. This
means that the farmer's field will have
an assortment of plants, some tall, some
short, some resistant to pests, some
not. This makes for a crop that is
difficult for farmers to care for and
harvest. So, what have we learned about
hybrids? Let's recap. Characteristics
are controlled by genes which come in
different versions like different suits
of the same playing card. Many crops are
inbred until each plant has the same
version of each gene so that they are
genetically identical and can be
uniformly cared for and harvested. When
these inbred lines are crossed, the
resulting hybrid has even better
characteristics than either of the
parents. This is called hybrid vigor.
Farmers often greatly prefer hybrid
plants, but don't save the seeds that
they produce. This is because seeds
produced by hybrid crops grow into
plants that are not uniform and lack
characteristics favored by farmers and
consumers. And now you know one reason
why farmers choose to buy new seeds each
year.
[Music]